>> WHILE MILLIONS CELEBRATED GAY
PRIDE A LEFT WING MOB ATTACKED A
GAY ASIAN JOURNALISTS.
>> [BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [SCREAMING].
>> [BLEEP].
>> [CHEERING].
>> A LOT OF BEEPING.
HE ENDED UP IN THE ER WITH BRAIN
INJURIES.
THESE GAME OF THRONES PLAYERS
HIT THEM WITH MILK SHAKES THAT
MAY HAVE CONTAINED MORE THAN
MILK.
THESE ANTIFA THUGS.
A GUY WHO MONITORS FAKE HATE
BECOMES THE VICTIM OF REAL HATE
BY SCUM WHO PRETENDING TO BOD
BY SCUM WHO PRETENDING TO BE
REAL.
WHAT ABOUT THE MAYOR?
>> YOU TALK ABOUT ANTIFA?
THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THEM THAT
ARE TRUE TO A CAUSE.
THAT IS A GOOD CAUSE.
THEY WANT SOCIAL JUSTICE IN THAT
CONTEXT.
>> SO HE ASKS EXCUSE THE
VIOLENCE AND ONE HILLARY CLINTON
STAFFER SAID HE ASKED FOR IT
FILMING IT.
KATE WRITE
KATE WRIING IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" CALLING FOR BORDER WALL
AGENTS TO BE DOCK.
THE MEDIA FROM AFAR DIRECTS THE
MOB AND RELY ON INTIMIDATION TO
MAKE THE CASE PERHAPS BECAUSE
THEIR WORDS FAIL THEM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STATES WHERE
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW TO WEAR A
MASK BUT NOT THERE.
THEY COULD HAVE CHANGED IT.
>> YOU HAVE GOOD REASON TO BE
WARY OF ANY MONUMENT THAT THEY
WANT TO WEAR MASKS.
THE WHOLE POINT IS WEARING
MASKS.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT ANDY NO
IS ALWAYS REFERRED TO AS A RIGHT
WING JOURNALIST.
NOT JUST A JOURNALIST.
THAT PART SHOWS THE INTOLERANCE
OF THIS.
SAM PARENT TWEETED THAT THERE IS
A THIN LINE BETWEEN CIVILIZATION
AND NON-CIVILIZATION.
I USED TO LIKE PORTLAND.
I WOULD NEVER GO THERE.
I AM LIKE YOU AND THE DR.
>> THE DR IS FINE COMPARED TO
PORTLAND.
THE MAYOR AND POLICE ARE NOT
DOING ANYTHING.
>> THEY JUST LET EACH OTHER GO
AT.
IT WE SAW THAT IN BALTIMORE
WHERE YOU GIVE THEM ROOM TO
RIOT.
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE.
IT LED TO PEOPLE GETTING ART.
I AGREE THE MEDIA WILL GIVE
LICENSE TO THIS TYPE OF
VIOLENCE.
LOOK AT THE HEADLINE.
CONSERVATIVE JOURNALIST SAYS HE
WAS ATTACKED.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THE TORONTO
RAPTORS SAY THEY WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
WELL, IT WAS ON TV.
WHY HASN'T THE MEDIA FOUND ANY
OF THESE ATTACKERS AND
IDENTIFIED THEM.
BECAUSE SOME GUY ON TWITTER WILL
TWEET A VIDEO OF THE PRESIDENT
BODY SLAMMING A REPORTER AND THE
PRESS IS ON THEIR DOOR THE NEXT
DAY.
WE HAVE HEARD FOR 2 YEARS HOW
TRUMP'S RHETORIC IS CAUSING
VIOLENCE AGAINST JOURNALISTS.
NOW, WE HAVE A CONSERVATIVE
JOURNALIST WHO HAS BEEN
VIOLENTLY ATTACKED AND THEY
BURIED THE STORY.
I WANT TO SAY ONE MORE THING.
IF SOMEONE THROWS A MILK SHAKE
AT ME, MAKE IT CHOCOLATE!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I AM LACTOSE INTOLERANT.
SO THAT IS ASSAULT WITH A DEADY
WEAPON.
>> MASKS, YOU ARE LESS LIKELY TO
HURT SOMEBODY --
>> I THINK VIOLENCE IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
IT'S REPREHENSIBLE AND SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
THAT WAS UNCOMFORTABLE TO WATCH.
IT SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING, BUT
IT SOUNDED TO ME WHEN I LISTENED
TO YOU AS IF YOU WERE SAYING
THAT THE EXCESSES HERE ARE NOW
TO BE LABELLING ALL PEOPLE WHO
ARE NEO-NAZIS AND THE FASCISTS
THAT IT REPRESENTS ALL OF
ANTIFA.
>> IT IS REPRESENTATIVE OF ALL
OF THE ANTIFA.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY
REPRESENTATIVE THAN THE GUY
SENDING THE BOMBS TO CNN OR THE
GUY THAT SHOT UP THE SYNAGOGUE
IN PITTSBURGH OR THE GUY
SENTENCED TO LIFE LAST WEEK FOR
HIS HATE CRIMES IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
>> WHICH WE CONDEMNED.
>> BUT I WOULD SAY THIS WORRIES
ME.
YOU SAY, JUAN, THAT'S NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF EVERYONE.
>> THAT'S NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE RIGHT WING BOMBERS.
>> RIGHT.
>> OR THE GUY THAT MOWED THE
WOMAN DOWN.
THAT'S NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
NEO-NAZIS.
ALL OF ANTIFA IS LIKE THIS.
>> NO.
>> YES, THEY ARE.
THEY ALL DRESS IN BLACK AND
WIELD CLUBS.
>> THEY ARE ALL UNEMPLOYED AND
UGLY.
>> IF YOU ARE SHOWING UP WITH A
CROWBAR, YOU HAVE NO GOOD
INTENTIONS WITH A MASK.
HERE'S MY CONCERN.
REMEMBER WHEN CHRIS CUOMO WAS ON
AIR TALKING ABOUT CHARLESTON AND
NEO-NAZIS AND ANTIFA.
HE SAID ONE IS FIGHTING HATE.
THERE IS A JUSTIFICATION OF WHAT
ANTIFA DOES BECAUSE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE TARGETING.
BUT THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WHAT CONCERNS ME, THEY THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT WITH THAT MENTALITY.
WHAT ANTIFA IS DOING IS OKAY
DEPENDING ON WHO THEY ARE
TARGETING AND WHO GETS HARMED.
THAT'S A DANGEROUS MENTALITY TO
HAVE.
AND THE MAYOR TED WHEELER, LAST
YEAR, A BUILDING IN PORTLAND,
OREGON WAS UNDER SIEGE.
THESE ANTIFA PROTESTORS WERE NOT
LETTING INDIVIDUALS IN AND OUT
OF THE BUILDING.
THEY STOPPED A CAR FROM LEAVING.
THIS MAYOR WAS TWEETING I DON'T
SUPPORT "ICE" SO I AM NOT
TELLING POLICE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT.
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR.
>> SHOULDN'T THE CITIZENS OF
PORTLAND DO SOMETHING?